LaVar ball got banned from ESPN,
which is hilarious when ESPN vans anybody.
Cause like no one gives a about ESPN anymore.
They just watch your on the internet. Um,
I mean, it's like what, five years till ESPN isn't a network anymore
because of like Barstool sports and uh,
house of highlights. Um,
but LaVar ball was banned from being, uh, from,
I apparently making a sexual innuendo to, uh, uh, a female reporter,
which straight up who cares. But, um,
it was really funny because I actually didn't know this,
but I Googled it a little bit, but cause she said let's switch gears.
And you said, Oh, I switched gears with you anytime. And I was like, who cares?
And then I Googled what I was like, am I missing?
So like a Google was switched gears means apparently that means going from like
having sex with a vaginal intercourse and then going to anal,
which I think is a stretch. But whatever. I mean,
I would absolutely say something like, well,
I'd switch gears with you anytime and not know that,
but they banned him from any ESPN thing, which is hilarious.
Cause like who gives a about ESPN straight up? Um.
ESPN.
Is, is something that's like on, in the background. Like that's what ESPN is.
Imagine working for a company where you just are elevator
music, dude.
Like even people who watch sports are like watching it on their phone,
on like house of highlights or analysis,
you know, like they're doctors.
Uh, so I don't, I, Hey ESPN, can you ban me too?
Just asking? Um,
Uh, I dunno.
I feel like just her like being like awkward and like annoying about that and
about like making a stink about it. I don't know if she did or not,
but like that kind of like pushed the movement back a little bit. Like just,
I would say that to a guy and make a joke.
It's LaVar ball.
You know.
You're not interviewing Elon Musk. It's LaVar ball.
You put him on your station to get views because he says dumb.
And now you're going to ban him for saying dumb.
What the is wrong with you?
Add a touch ESPN, outta here with your stupid.
Yes. That's what ESPN stand for. Stands for. [inaudible] pointless news.
ESPN says for sir pointless news.
Uh, please. Nobody that nobody's w nobody gives a.
The only guy they got that's worth watching is that guy looks like ludicrous.
His uncle ludicrous, his cousin.
What's that guy that they gave 10 million to.
They should be giving the stars of a network more than
$10 million, dude. That's how bad he SPN is.
They gave the guy a contract.
Who's that guy that looks like ludicrous is a brother with
diabetes, dude. They, they,
they should be giving him
$80 million. This is a network.
This is their highest paid guy, $10 million.
Steven, a Smith.
He's the only guy that's worth watching all those other
CUCs. I look, I don't watch the ESPN, so I don't know,
but it's always just some guy, you know,
maybe do they even have guys like Charles Barkley and Shaquille O'Neal or is it
like, it's like, this is the guy.
Yeah.